the Joe Rogan experience there's a lot
of people that will tell you things and
some of those things seem like [ __ ]
but inside those things is some
undeniable truths about how we should
live our lives and how we should view
the world and how we can sort of Union
unite each other with love and
understanding and we can connect
anything it's um like a murder mystery
it's not figure out life right but it's
it is like a murder mystery it's more
probably more complicated because it's
never over murder mysteries have an N
yeah right life is just as long as there
is life as most people are said most
people man I know some people they're so
happy they the last thing on their mind
is trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
this is all about they're just living
their life and it's all about their
family and they don't give a [ __ ] about
Iran they don't give a [ __ ] about NASA
they're just living their life and man I
envy that [ __ ] I'm trying to move closer
to that I envy that [ __ ] hey you know
what people tell me you know like yo
that's all you do is study conspiracy
theories and I'm like no on the weekends
dude on the weekends I am blue pilling
myself on the weekends baseball with my
son karate we've got the [ __ ]
watching the Disney cartoons with all
the space [ __ ] and I we I blue pill with
a [ __ ] I don't try to get my son into
conspiracy theories at all that's gonna
be later I'm like I just wanna that's
gonna be later as later I'll get him
when he's like certain today but right
now he can't handle it there's no way
there's no way it shouldn't ask him to
and all his whole life every minute is
happiness just love and happiness and we
just we just want to make careful every
day he loves school more than anything
he loves school more than [ __ ] he
loves school and then after school it's
all about fun and he decides what we're
gonna do he calls the shots
you're gonna go to karate because today
we're gonna do karate and then we're
gonna cos he's all in the baseball too
and then we're gonna go to the batting
cages my boom that's it we go to karate
batting cages that I go teach jiu-jitsu
then the next day he'll say daddy I
think we're gonna I'm gonna take a
relaxation day worked a lot the last
couple of days let's go get a let's
order pizza from from Dino's in Burbank
amazing and then we'll watch
some teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles he's
all about teeth he decides and then
every day it's a different thing what he
wants it let's go to the movies today
after school this is an evolution of you
learning from like the pain of your
childhood and like doing all the right
things I do the opposite with it is my
dad my dad had 19 kids and I was just
one kid with my mom was like a weird
offside like he had a family with five
kids and then he got a bunch of other
women pregnant he was all over the place
truck driver he had 19 kids I was one of
19 yet I had eight different chicks he
was banging and he never I found out I
met I met a couple of my half-brothers
and half-sisters they were were actually
part of his real family and we met one
day we went to the Old Spaghetti Factory
in Hollywood and he took they told me
all about him and I didn't know I
thought he had five kids he had a family
with five kids and my mom was some chick
you know he was seeing on the side
that's what I thought I didn't know he
had a bunch of others it goes how much
they go she goes how many my staff
sister goes how many I was happened well
half-sister have brother cuz how many
kids do you think your dad has I said
six so hot try 19 damn I know he's like
hey Leo Gracie holy [ __ ] real someone
and one thing that he never told anybody
never said the words I love you to
anybody to his like real family he never
said it to me because I would seem like
once a year that the words never came
out of never told my mom that apparently
he's one of those guys that will never
say he'll love you to anybody and I'm
the opposite dude I tell my son I look
him in the eye every day saying you know
who loves you the most you know I don't
know I love you the most and I whisper
in his your mic
you know I'll kill anybody for you don't
you ever forget that
well we're getting crazy oh it's crazy
but it is important yeah I mean it's a
funny thing good now it's a funny thing
like first is like okay dad okay and now
cuz I'm not gonna let you forget daddy I
won't forget I caught you promise cuz I
won't forget it I just want to make sure
you don't forget then it goes okay
because I daddy I won't forget I promise
welcome every day every beautiful man
you know you you've really embraced to
be the dad taller Hatters man I'm living
for him my that's why I shaved my head
I'm like what the [ __ ] am i doing
washing my hair transplant scar in the
back of my head I would have shaved my
head a long time ago
but I just decided like this is so
pointless it looks terrible
yeah keep paying to get haircut always
act like [ __ ] everybody online is calm
like telling me I'm turning Joe Rogan
[Applause]